Vous l'avez vu dans le titre : j'ai participé à un projet de web documentaire avec Arte, c'est trop stylé !
Merci beaucoup Arte, ça s'appelle "Homo Digitalis".
Alors c'est un web documentaire de 7 épisodes de 10 minutes et genre ça parle du transhumanisme
de ce qu'est homo sapiens, le fait que l'humanité change énormément, change très vite
et que du coup bah voilà il y'a plein de repères qu'on est en train de perdre ou de réinventer
et donc ça parle de ça à travers plein de thématiques
l'amour, l'amitié, les loisirs, le travail, etc. donc voilà c'était vraiment un kiff à faire !
Vous allez sur homodigitalis.tv pour
voir les épisodes.
Il y a aussi un quiz qu'ils ont fait, en fait, parce qu'ils font un partenariat avec une équipe de recherche
pour essayer d'en savoir un petit peu plus, de comprendre un peu nos habitudes,
comment nous on voit tout ça et je vous mets le lien du test dans la description.
Alors, je sais qu'ils visent 10'000 participants au moins pour fin janvier, voilà je sais pas si on va y arriver
si on arrive c'est cool parce que plus on donne d'infos et plus justement ces organismes là nous aident à comprendre,
nous aident à faire des documentaires comme ça.
Évidemment, c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur et vous savez pourquoi si vous avez vu ma dernière vidéo
sur la transformation cybernétique, si vous l'avez pas vu
c'est peut-être le moment de la voir
je sais pas si j'ai le droit de vous montrer des extraits
de à quoi ça ressemble si j'ai le droit de vous montrer des extraits ça ressemble à ça :
quand l'intelligence artificielle nous aura dépassé
deviendrons-nous les chatons domestiques de nos robots ? Un peu partout sur la planète, les pionniers de la technologie planchent déjà sur une solution :
l'amélioration des performances de notre cerveau. Ma collègue allemande Hélène Farès est allée voir sur le terrain comment tout ça fonctionne
Bienvenue dans Homo Digitalis. A partir de quand nous ne seront plus de véritables êtres humains ? Aujourd'hui on va parler du cerveau
comment dans le futur on va pouvoir interagir avec lui, comment l'améliorer,
comment le modifier.
En plus, ce qui était stylé, c'est que bah j'ai travaillé avec des professionnels du son, de la voix, etc.
pour poser ma voix, parler plus, parce qu'évidemment un documentaire ou un web documentaire d'Arte on ne parle pas avec la même vitesse
qu'une vidéo Youtube et ce que j'aimais dans ce projet c'est que ça ne présente pas les trucs en mode
"waouh c'est hyper dangereux" ou "waouh c'est hyper cool", ça les présente et c'est un petit peu à nous de se faire notre propre opinion.
Moi, j'interviens parfois sur certains sujets ou en gros je donne mon avis ou je donne une idée
ou je réagis à certaines choses
j'ai pas écrit sur le fond
du documentaire mais en tout cas voilà c'est un truc que je trouve super intéressant et j'ai hâte d'avoir vos retours
j'ai eu beaucoup de retours déjà via Twitter et Snapchat de gens qui ont beaucoup aimé, donc voilà, il manquait plus que vous sur Youtube
j'espère que ça vous plaira aussi, n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires, je les lis tous, voilà, love, peace,
et on se voit très très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo !
Alors je la refais parce que j'ai râté le clin d'oeil à la fin. Voilà c'était ça.